welcome to this video playing hockey
with white not happening often i usually
have boobs have black against them and
you played like 30-something games
remarkable yeah he's playing like this
hmm with g6 isn't it interesting to play
and some in some kind of same ish style
now maybe it's going night h5 here
quickly okay stopping this for the
moment and now the queenside let me do
something there Joe at least I don't
have a king on g1 that you can quickly
check mate so can I go with King to see
too hmm canceling my hand
night bg7 so do I am guru p 1 year I
think I do sort with that a couple of
nuts here don't need some fuel for my
brain I think okay let's see I can open
up stuff he has night some something to
see five but I don't see really how I
make any progress without a four
97 I go 85
would love to do something with my d3
Bishop some somewhere but it doesn't
seem to be happening quickly if at all
maybe after a five a later Bishop see to
a four it's doing something for that
piece at least currently it looks like
he's not getting anywhere soon with his
King side play so that was was clear I
think B takes so here he wants to check
with the night I guess anyway he cannot
take on a five in this kind of position
i believe so i can go and quincy one and
creepy to these kind of things if you
take say 5i take b8 and go queen a3 that
must be good okay i'm going to take and
now yeah maybe taking I mean he has to
take with the part I think and I'd be
five maybe Quincy one wasn't really
necessary here now that I think of it
okay so I wonder if taking here as an
option on I think it actually is let's
just take it dark squared Bishop isn't
doing much here anyway and this way i'm
at least invading somewhat quickly with
roo Kade and so on so okay eight
and queen a 3 j's taking them and now i
wonder yeah maybe let's bring another
night and I need Bishop c22 a for this
kind of thing I wonder if Queen h1 is an
idea going over what is he doing there
Queen age 5 yeah I'm going here so that
it probably has to reconsider queen age
5 going there okay a half 97 96 and
thought that this would be rather okay
giving me play on the light squares and
I 93 is just putting the night out of
the game ride anyway 96 was the idea and
here we go
yeah I do we do at the night is just
totally misplaced there 1g 3a my love
you were looking some kind of silly
tactic that can happen okay in 95 I look
on the seventh set actually better look
a 74 Queen h7 made for the night I don't
know what's better let's play the night
it's just playing without this piece on
g 3m oops sorry about that that's my
coffee maker
it's really loud yeah now you're sitting
there okay look a eight is the most
obvious move well again that should be
ok so this one the only p is not doing
anything is my bishop can I use that
Bishop somehow mmm am I already here out
for some tactics mmm Queen g5 doesn't
convince my bishop enters that the game
it definitely is definitely over I don't
see how this would happen I mean he
cannot really do much kingi seven or
something ok I'm going here for possible
Queens Bishop c 2 and so on is he
threatening something here or not Queen
age six maybe time 105
hmm maybe Queens you five Queen g6
the thing is I'm still trying to make
good moves instead of winning on time
this is sometimes very impractical I
could just win on time this game by
playing some quick quick whatever moves
but I'm not doing that I still try to
play good and sometimes this is so
that's sad not very practical
mmm that would definitely wasn't the
best way of playing check no doubt about
that oh it's a check I totally forgot
that it's a check okay so maybe I can
get the fishing wire f1 into the game
Queen age 30 no time at all black
forfeits on time wrong yeah Jim I didn't
find the knock out there and I should
there should be something really with
this here there's this kind of position
and Jonas is giving you I hate it I hate
the computer just just just look so bad
here with this this off night and
against the knight on d5 and its equal
yeah maybe if there's no breakthrough it
just might be equal no Kim this should
be better but I couldn't find a way
really I invested lots of time but I
couldn't find a way to improve it this
wasn't even helping me chan would be 70
black is even better have tried
something maybe I just have to stay
there nothing happens Jim very weird
very weird okay well it was a good fight
thanks for watching